la juve est sérieux tu tu sais combien
de garde compliqué en ce moment à hong
hong et touche tous ces deux touches
touchés de près ou de loin par par la
maladie tu sais que notre papa a été
touché par l'aco vide alors comment tu
l'as vécu toi alors ah bah moi c'était
pendant le confinement en plus donc
c'est vrai que c'était c'est assez
compliqué et c'est vrai que tu en voilà
gt gt entre les missions et essayer de
m'occuper du à distance que je pouvais
pas aller le voir
il a passé lui il a passé quatre mois à
l'hôpital et c'est vrai qu'ils sont nés
sorti miraculeusement parce qu'ils la
voient là et aujourd'hui je suis très
heureux je vois là mais chaque jour
c'est vrai que je vis dans l'angoissé de
me dire est ce qui va racaille phase qui
va le rattraper
est-ce qu'il va retourner à l'hôpital ça
reste un traumatisme mais c'est vrai que
voilà j'ai je me suis dit à un moment ça
va être compliqué et on cyril mon frérot
tu sais que tout le monde tu adores 1 je
te le dis je le répète tous les jours tu
testes plein de séquences d'aidé nouveau
délire ça change tout le temps là
aujourd'hui certain que c'est moi mais
est ce que tu crois que je dois revenir
après les vacances et je vous le dis
après les vacances on a décidé avec les
équipes et ça c'est vraiment un scoop de
faire venir une marionnette par rapport
à une actu tous les jours une
marionnette des guignols
voilà et de refaire venir par exemple si
on parle de d'énergie mais qui commence
on aura un nikos voilà ciré et voilà et
tous les jours on aura une marionnette
pour une séquence